telefonistas de una mutua de salud de
día recolectores de fondos para la lucha
y prevención del VIH por la noche es
cuarta vez que estos trabajadores se
ponen voluntariamente al teléfono para
recibir las donaciones como parte del
fin de semana sin acción una colecta de
fondos a través de un programa de
televisión
Somos unos cuarenta que venimos de toda
la región de París estamos con colegas
con los que trabajamos hace un tiempo y
no nos habíamos visto yo vine con mi
equipo de Bobby estamos muy contentos de
trabajar en grupo pero en una acción
diferente que nos saca de la rutina hay
muy buen ambiente reímos compartimos Y
nos sentimos útiles
en 2022 y de acción recogió menos dinero
debido a la pandemia pero el covid
también impactó la detección del VIH en
Francia 174 mil personas viven con el
virus pero un 13% no lo sabe porque no
se analiza falta de información la
sensación de que el VIH se ha
transformado en una enfermedad Crónica
Pero además en los últimos años los
casos positivos aumentan en los mayores
de 50 años
se trata de personas que después de una
ruptura conyugal recomiendan una vida
sexual con otra persona pero sin el
reflejo de usar preservativo u otro
método de prevención
un ambiente
recogió dinero en bares y calles pero
también intenta suplir la falta de
información
piensen en hacerse un análisis cada tres
meses o después de 10 parejas sexuales
si después de 10 pasa rápido en una
semana ya lo tienes que hacer
una persona seropositiva pero con carga
viral indetectable no transmite el virus
podemos acostarnos con una persona cero
positiva indetectable sin problemas y
eso hay que decirlo repetidamente
la colecta tiene lugar en 14 ciudades el
año pasado
un motivo para estar orgulloso